bueno tal vez
[Música]
acción
reunimos
y hablar sobre cualquier tema de interés
y evidentemente salta a la vista en
interés
entonces
con la lengua
de muchísimos minutos de
tenemos la que es
entonces hablen
porque hablar de lengua la lengua con
órganos
cada paso que damos la consigna
sin cambios que repercuta
notablemente en la vida cotidiana
toda actividad humana requiere cambios y
cambios y el lenguaje no es la excepción
evidentemente que para qué
usado y empleado
típicas permite ciertos cambios brutales
pueden causar un cierto
rechazo en algún momento
al momento de usar la lengua como
herramientas de comunicación
sencillamente porque no sabemos cómo
recibir ese cambio o rechazarla ok para
que esto no ocurra entonces debemos
saber qué
lo más importante en la característica
muy importante
es que precisamente el patrimonio
fundamental
incluso es la creación más
entonces con ello podemos llegar
iremos por muchos
yo hablo porque necesito comunicarme
porque preparar un discurso
sencillamente no
pero atlante es también
en este caso me encantaría comentarles
que
todos los días que hablamos podemos ver
que muchas de ellas o sencillamente
hablan para comunicarse ejemplo mis
padres y mis estudiantes no tuvieron una
oportunidad de aprender a hablar a
trabajar
a lo mejor ocurre también
que si hablamos con ellos podemos
aprender tantas cosas sin andar
buscándole si habla bien no habrá mal
hablaban con respeto
entonces de aquí viene
cuándo
porque es muy importante en el discurso
si guardan una estructura cuidar la
lengua
pero en el sentido
por qué
y evidentemente si hablamos con nuestros
abuelos
el contenido con
aún habiendo pasado por una universidad
aún teniendo una mina
entonces
a todo esto muchas personas cada vez que
pronuncian o están en presencia de
alguien que dicen saber hablar
pues comienzan a poner etiquetas sobre
a aquellas personas que se encargan
etiquetas como guardián de la lengua
como herederos de ellos
y entonces comienza a ver una barrera
y esa barrera comienza a verse desde el
cambio porque todos los cambios de los
que los que dije en principio estos
cambios
no lo que no queremos es poner barreras
tales también porque evidentemente sí
pero tales pueden venir en la medida
pueden verse pueden afectar un en la
medida en que los comemos o creó una
barrera o sencillamente los canalizó
para enriquecer el vocabulario en este
caso ok
tengo un ejemplo claro de dos palabras
que parece que han sido el mal del siglo
pasado
[Música]
este signo también
debes poner o colocar
evidentemente cuando hablamos sobre todo
[Música]
me mima tan rico que nos da tantas
tantas opciones como
corre el riesgo también
d
pisarla bien 4 millas
nuestra identidad más importante que
por lo tanto escuchamos siempre
las personas que se colocan rojas de la
pena
las personas que se colocan 6
y hay personas de color
ok pero nunca se pone porque
vertiginosamente ha ocurrido
que éramos
infantes éramos niños
la maestra nos marco diciendo
si no se han relegado funciones tu pobre
verbo poner solamente el de dinero
entonces nos olvidamos de qué
el verbo poner existe
porque todo el mundo coloca porque todo
el mundo todo el mundo usa el pobre
verbo colocar entonces sea sin querer se
ha convertido en reos
quizás en hombres reos el delito de
nuestra manito
cuando se usa
indiscriminadamente el pobre verbo local
que no quiero ser mujer
yo quiero ser nunca tal verbo por que
lean
lo han cargado de tanto trabajo
a lo mejor ha perdido un poco el sentido
y la importancia siempre
poner tiene 46 excepciones
en colocar cuentas sólo con cinco
excepciones entonces tenemos mayores
probabilidades
cometer errores cada mes
aunque sea cero porque en la escuela nos
dijeron eso en la fe han satanizado
tanto al pobre verbo poner lo han
desterrado que parece que se encuentra
en una lápida si aquí se encuentra el
verbo
porque porque la gente ha usado un matiz
y eso nos dice matilde exponer se
encuentra
cuando una chica se va a maquillar sin
gusta diferentes maldición
pero no se maquilla mucho se pasa porque
si no puede verse
también lo mismo
entre las 46 excepciones que no voy a
dar
detalles sobre esas 46 voy a dar unos
ejemplos en los cuales se usa mucho el
cuerpo colocar a lo mejor ustedes
también como yo me coloqué nerviosa a la
hija de colocarme el nombre de colocar
el negativo me coloque la camisa me
colocó el ridículo voy a colocar la
queja me coloque rojo rojo de auto ropa
de la pena le colocó el saldo por lo que
me la cédula por favor que colocarlas el
espaldar de la silla en posición
vertical y finalmente la gente
si levante la mano quien ha escuchado
todos
verdad ya lo mejor todo porque
evidentemente se nos va
poco a poco se nos ha alimentado el
sobreuso quizás el sobrevalorado uso que
tienen
el pobre verbo colocar dejando por
debajo tal que realmente no son
variantes
entonces
sepamos el verbo poner sigue vivo y que
está allí para ser usada entonces con
clase se dice
pero no sé cuándo
en base un momento sí
ahora en qué contexto puede usar el
colocar y no el poner porque también hay
existe ese momento incontables y es el
rey en que el verbo único que pueda ser
usado es colocar
tenemos nazismo septiembre dice poner a
alguien con algo en su debido lugar
tiempo y red y resulta que de las cinco
excepciones la 1 y la 5
de amarillo porque en realidad ahí puede
existir la sinonimia con el poder o sea
que no puedo decir yo pongo alguien en
su sitio o sencillamente colocó a
alguien
eso es correcto de la misma manera que
una de las excepciones dice dicho él al
pueblo de una droga causar un estado
eufórico si el alcohol
pero también es decir el humor
en ese contexto también
es correcto pero tiene la sinonimia de
poner entonces yo
en ganas de no equivocarme en un
asaltante que tenga alguna duda pero en
qué casos pues todos
solamente colocar
usar por lugar de invertir dinero
invertir dinero es en el banco cuando
colocas el dinero a plazo fijo por
ejemplo
por lo que ese es un contexto real de
estar con colocar él no va a tener sino
ninja componer se usa colocar de la
misma manera acomodar a alguien
poniéndole en algún estado o empleo
en persona en el puerto de
es mostrar algún producto o
sencillamente coloque a la venta por
mercadolibre
en ese caso podemos saber en realidad el
verbo colocar tiene sobre
3 puso porque los otros dos también se
controlan con el color
ya nos harían 46
entonces 3
yo recomiendo por
póngase
s
en un contexto pero
si hay algo que se llama
siempre ha oído a que los sonidos que le
salga a la vida
y aunque usted no lo crea a lo mejor al
amanecer
[Música]
porque esto no es solamente alguno
mejor
un abismo
para nada esto no se trata tampoco de
un empecinamiento nacionalista
es sencillamente saber quiénes van a
salir
cuando vayamos a usar este tipo de
palabras no la usemos demasiado y otra
cosa ocurre con la palabra demasiado hay
mucha gente
dice digamos demasiado sea usted lugar
dan demasiado
salga corriendo
no haga caso porque mandé a esa persona
a revisión psiquiátrica porque el que
ama demasiado
definitivamente
sí
qué ocurre cuando una fruta está
demasiado
entonces cuando las personas hablan de
usar demasiado la palabra demasiado
tratan o están incurriendo en un error
las cosas que se hacen en demasía hasta
qué
sí
hablar y un poco
pretender abordar temas que
ah
[Aplausos]